meditation on the opening verses of
surah al
namely the two verses
verse number four and verse number five
in which Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
describes himself
as
the one who
marked marked the decree
with the pen. This is the meaning that
we discussed last night.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala then said
he taught the one who taught the human
being what he did not previously know.
Another meaning of
Subhan Allah.
[Silence]
Fore
we mentioned last night the meaning one
of the meanings of
meaning the one who wrote the decree
and the destiny of all that was to be in
the heavens and the earth until the day
of judgment 50,000 years before the
first creation as our prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam tells us.
But another meaning of this verse,
he is the one who taught the human being
by way of the pen.
Sometimes we overlook just how powerful
the pen really is. We take it for
granted. It's something that's like
this, the sky above us or the earth
beneath our feet. the sun rising. It's
something that happens so often and it's
such a constant in our existence that
it's easy to overlook the incredible
blessing of the pen and the history that
the human being has with the pen. The
pen. The pen is so important, such a
great
tool and an incredible blessing from
Allah that he swore by the pen.
He swore by the pen
and that which they use that which they
use the pen to write.
You, oh Muhammad, by the blessing and
grace of your Lord, are not
of are not in any way insane or mad.
And so what does he use to defend the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam? He
swears by the pen.
In defense of the prophet, he swears by
the pen.
And that tradition from the day that
verse was revealed
until Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala takes
back and brings home the last believer
on earth.
The scholars will always in every time
in every generation be there to defend
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam and the
Quran and the prophet's message with the
pen.
And so the pen, imagine if we were
unable to communicate with one another
with the pen. Imagine
if all we could do is communicate our
knowledge to each other verbally, but we
were not able to write it.
How could we ever advance
as humanity has advanced throughout the
years? How could we ever pass down
knowledge? How could we ever communicate
knowledge to the next generation?
It would continue to thin and thin,
meaning the the amount of scholars in
any field would continue to become less
and less and less until the knowledge is
lost. But by way of the pen and the
blessing of the pen, we are able to
communicate
ideas,
information, knowledge
and our knowledge transcends
almost transcends time and place.
Ali
passed away in the year 310.
Here I am sitting in Arizona
almost 1,200 years later
1,200 years later I sit down and I read
the words of
as he spoke those words to his students
when he wrote his taps. How am I able to
do this? How is a nei
alkari the companions? How are they able
to communicate their knowledge to us?
And that knowledge is able to cut across
unfathomable distances and cut across
centuries of time by way of the pen.
And that is why it is commonly mentioned
and said that the pen is the most mighty
tool the human being has ever been
given. It is far more mighty than the
sword. It is far more influential.
The pen is what we use to communicate
ideas to each other. And an idea cannot
be killed.
As a matter of fact, the more you try to
kill and eradicate an idea, the more
prevalent it becomes.
And this is why the scholars have
mentioned with regards to the
scholarship of Islam
that
the blood of the martyrs
is only surpassed by
is only exceeded and surpassed by the by
the pen of the scholars by the ink of
the scholars. The greatest position any
human being can have after the sending
of our prophet sallall.aii wasallam on
this earth and after the seal of
prophethood is scholarship. There is no
higher position. And when we mention
scholarship
that is what is meant by a sudik. What
is a sudik? A sudik is someone who
believes in the prophet sallall.aii
Wasam so intensely and vehemently that
u doubts
are that doubts are unable to be able
to penetrate this person's heart due to
the strength of their belief and this
comes only with scholarship. the pen.
Allah described himself as the one who
taught the human being by way of the
pen. It's something specific to us. It
is an incredible blessing from Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in the
next verse,
he is the one who taught the human being
what he did not know. What do we recite
every day?
Morning and evening encouraged to
recite.
Allah says with regards to his knowledge
that the creation is unable
to earn or encompass or uncover or
discover of Allah's knowledge anything
except that which Allah allows them to
discover of his knowledge subhanahu
wa'ta'ala.
So he is the one who taught those who
argue against Allah and argue against
the prophets and messengers. Those who
argue against the
law of Allah, against the Quran, against
the Sunnah,
who is the one who allowed them to have
the knowledge to be able to bite the
hand that feeds them? Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
These verses were the first verses
revealed to the prophet. We fast forward
to a time just before he made hijra. The
next verses
are regarding the antagonists of the
human of of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. After all these blessings,
recite, read
in the name of your Lord who has created
all of the creation.
He has created the human being
specifically from a clinging clot.
Recite and your Lord is ever generous.
The one who taught by way of the pen
taught the human being what he did not
know prior, what he was unable to obtain
on his own. What is the next verse? He
says,
he said,
Well,
[Silence]
he
Notice the wording here. Allah didn't
say the son of Adam, Benny Adam. He
refers to the human being by his name
which is alins.
Let us examine this word for a moment.
What does this word mean in the Quran?
The word insan in the Quran
is used to refer to one of two things.
Number one, it's used to refer to just
the type of creature. The category of
creature, the species is a human being
in said. The other
is the descriptions that follow the
nature of the human being. When Allah
wishes to mention the human being
and articulate his disposition and his
nature, how he naturally is and how
engrossed he is in his in his ways and
in his impulses,
he will use the word insaid.
So you notice in the Quran that Allah
when he describes the human being as
hasty
here the word comes up again in a
dispraising light.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
the human being was created and is
naturally hasty no patience. He refers
to the human being as
indeed the human being is transgressive
by nature and ungrateful by nature.
Whenever the word insan is used in the
Quran, it calls back all of these
descriptions that Allah used with the
word insaiden.
So when Allah wishes to mention the
human being in the Quran and bring to
mind the nature of the human being, the
impulses, the negatives, he uses the
word insaid.
But when Allah wishes to mention
the
righteousness of the human being, the
honor, the nobility of the human being,
the gravitas of the human being, he
usually uses the phrase Iben Adam,
the son of Adam. Now he is mentioning
the forefather Adam. And all of those
praiseworthy attributes of Adam come to
mind when the when the term is used.
It's a very precise language. Where does
the word insan come from? What does it
mean?
for
[Silence]
Some scholars mention that the word
insan is derived originally
etmologically from the word
forgetfulness. The same word for
forgetfulness. Why? The human being is
forgetful.
This is why the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said
for
[Silence]
Buddha
Another and what is most prominent
amongst the scholars with regards to the
meaning of the name the word insan it is
derived from the origin of the same word
in which is to find comfort in company
meaning that the human being is not
alone. owner by nature. The human being
is a social creature by nature. Meaning
the human being can only find
fulfillment when he is with other human
beings. He has to have company from
other human beings. And this is what is
most cited. And the word could be from
both. As some scholars have mentioned
the human being. When you hear the word
insan in the Quran, you think of two
things. Number one, you think of his
forgetfulness.
And number two, you think of his social
nature, constantly wanting to have
company. When you think of these two
things, it is so fitting that Allah uses
the word insan in this context because
he says,
Indeed, the human being will
transgress
and will disobey.
How ironic is that? The human being will
disobey because he sees his riches and
thinks that he is independent and
doesn't need anyone. But he innately
needs others. Look at his name alins.
And so it is ironic,
it's paradoxical that the human being
thinks that he's independent but by his
very nature he needs other people let
alone his need for his creator. We will
end with that for tonight. just a
reminder tomorrow night inshallah
Saturday nights we'll have our weekly
question and answer session which is
a half an hour long. We try not to go
over a half an hour. It's Saturday
nights after I in place of our of the So
if you have any questions, if your if
any of the sisters have any questions,
want to write them down or send them up
with their husbands or brothers or
what have you, then this is a perfect
opportunity. It's an open question and
answer for anything that you want to ask
about, anything that comes to mind.
Muhammad he was.